you've got a country with tremendous
disparity of income you've got very rich
people on the one hand and abject
poverty and the other you have to be
sensitive to the fact that this gap
cannot continue to widen while there's a
large discontented number of people who
are looking at the inequities of
the environment as they see it too for
companies therefore I think there has to
be is a sensitivity to doing something
in the in the communities around which
you operate and in making an effort to
to raise the quality of life so that
there's there's not envy and distaste
for what was there but look the
companies look at in a more positive
sense and in enhancing the quality of
life of the people around them we expend
about 4% of our net profit in these
rural development activities and we do
it ourselves and someone may argue that
this is shareholders money which it is
but I think it has bought a sense of of
not just tolerance but a sense of
welcoming our companies in wherever
they've been and enhancing whatever
we've been trying to do in the product
area or the services area to a community
area of being part of the community